I was eight years old I remember that
day clearly like it happened just
yesterday my mother is a BD roller she
hand rolls country cigarettes to sustain
our family she is a hard worker and
spent 10 to 12 hours every day
rolling V DS that particular day she
came home and showed me her beady rollin
veg spoke she asked me how much money
she has earned that week I went through
that book and what caught my eyes were
her thumb prints on each page my mother
has never been to school she uses her
thumb prints instead of a signature to
keep recorder for earnings on that day
for some reason I wanted to teach her
how to hold a pen and write her name she
was reluctant at first she smiled
innocently and said no but deep down I
was sure she wanted to give it a try
with a little bit of persuasion and a
lot of effort we managed to write her
name her hands were trembling and her
face was beaming with pride as I watched
her do this for the first time in my
life I had a priceless feeling that I
could be of some use to this world that
feeling was very special because I am
not meant to be useful in rural India
girls are generally considered worthless
they're a liability or a burden if they
are considered useful it is only to cook
vicious keep the house clean or raise
children as a second daughter of my
conservative Indian family I was fairly
clear from a very early age that no one
expected anything from me I was
conditioned to believe that the three
identities that define me poor village
meant that I was to live a life of no
voice and no choice these three
identities forced me to think that I
should never have been born yet I was
all throughout my childhood as I rolled
biddies alongside my mother I would
wonder what did my future hold I often
asked my mother with a lot of anxiety
Amma will my life be different from
yours will I have a chance to choose my
life will I go to college and she would
reply back try to finish high school
first I am sure my mother did not mean
to discourage me she only wanted me to
understand that my dreams might be too
big for a girl in my village when I was
13 I found the autobiography of Helen
Keller Helen became my inspiration I
admired her indomitable spirit I wanted
to have a college degree like her so I
fought with my father and my relatives
to be sent to college and it worked
during my final year of my undergraduate
degree I desperately wanted to escape
from being forced into marriage so I
applied a fellowship program in Delhi
which is about 1,600 miles away from my
village
in fact I recall that the only way I
could fill out that application was
during my commute to college I did not
have access to computers so I had to
borrow a college junior cellphone as a
woman I could not be seen with a
cellphone so I used to huddle his phone
under my shawl and type as slowly as
possible to ensure that I would not be
heard after many rounds of interview I
got into the fellowship program with a
full scholarship
my father was confused my mother was
married my father was confused my mother
was worried but I felt butterflies in my
stomach because I was going to step out
of my village for the first time to
study in the national capital of the 97
fellows selected that year I was the
only rural college graduate there was no
one there who look like me or spoke like
me I felt alienated intimidated and
judged by many one fellow called me
coconut girl can you guess why anyone
that's because I applied a lot of
coconut oil to my hair
another asked me where I had learned to
speak English and some of my peers did
not prefer to have me on their
assignment inks because they thought I
would not be able to contribute to the
discussion I felt that many of my peers
believed that a person from rural India
could not supply anything of value yet
the majority of Indian population today
is rural I realized that stories like
mine were considered to be an exception
and never the expectation I believe all
of us are born into a reality which we
blindly accept until something awakens
us and a new world opens up when I saw
my mother's first signature on her beady
rolling vetch book when I fell the hot
Delhi yet against my face after a 50
hour train journey when I finally felt
free and let myself be I saw a glimpse
of that new world I longed for a world
where a girl like me is no longer
liability or a burden but a person of
use a person of value and a person of
worthiness by the way my fellowship
ended my life had changed not only had I
traced my lost voice but also had a
choice to make myself useful I was 22 I
came back to my village to set up Bodhi
tree Foundation an institution that
supports rural youth by providing them
with education life skills and
opportunities we work closely with our
rural youth to change their lives and to
benefit our communities how do I know my
institution is working well six months
ago we had a new joinee her name is
kuvira see I first spotted her in a
local college in Tirunelveli during one
of my training sessions as you can see
she has a smile which you can never
forget we guided her to get an
opportunity to studied Ashoka University
Delhi the best part of first story is
that she is now back at Bodhi tree
as a trainer working with dedication to
make a change in the lives of others
like her kuvira she doesn't want to feel
like an exception she want to be of use
to others in this world recently kuvira
cemented Anita who also comes from a
remote rural village lives in a 10 foot
by 10 foot home her parents also farm
libras kuvira si helped Anita Secor
admission in a prestigious undergraduate
program in the top university in India
with a full scholarship when Anita's
parents were reluctant to send her that
far we are sadistic administration
officials to speak to an ethos parents
and it worked and then there is Padma
Padma and I went to college together
she's a first in her entire village to
attend graduation she had been walking
with me at Bodhi tree until one day she
decides to go to graduate school I asked
her why she told me that she want to
make sure that she would never be a
liability or a burden to anyone at any
point in her life Padma Anita and kuvira
si grew up in the most of families and
communities one could only imagine yet
the journey of finding my usefulness in
this world served them in finding their
usefulness to this world of course there
are challenges I am aware chain does not
happen overnight a lot of my work
involves working with families and
communities to help them understand why
giving an education is useful for
everyone the quickest way to convince
them is by doing when they see their
kids getting a real education getting a
real job they begin to change the best
example is what happened at my home I
was recently given an award in
recognition of my social work by the
chief minister of my state that meant I
was going to be on television
every one workgroup dawn to the
television that morning including my
parents I would like to believe that
seeing her daughter on television made
my mother feel useful to hopefully she
will stop pressuring me to get married
now finding my use has helped me to
break free from the identities society
thrust on me poor village girl finding
my use has helped me to break free from
being boxed caged and bottled finding my
use has helped me to find my voice my
self-worth and my freedom I leave you
with this thought where do you feel
useful to this world because the answer
to that question is where you will find
your voice and your freedom thank you
[Applause]